Charges about the alleged evils of dark money,
otherwise known as anonymous charitable giving,
they're rife these days. Senator Sheldon
Whitehouse cites a "multi-hundred million
dollar covert operation" to promote conservative
judicial nominations through donor-advised funds,
a fast-growing means of individual charitable
giving that have become a target of progressive ire.
The reality is far different. In my latest
paper, I've reviewed grant data from the largest
donor-advised fund sponsors in the US. It turns
out that anonymous giving represents but a small
fraction of their donor's overall giving. Some
Americans do prefer to give anonymously due
to religious or cultural reasons. Most
don't. And public-policy-related giving — that
represents an even smaller percentage,
both of anonymous and overall giving.
And conservative organizations — they're not even
the leading recipients of anonymous DAF money.
The top 10 anonymously supported grantees in 2020
included the SPLC, Planned Parenthood, and the ACLU.
Memo to Senator Whitehouse: Dark money's
not whatyou think it is.
Are you concerned about dark money? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know whatother topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.